Hi everyone and welcome back to another video.
Today I thought I'd make something that I haven't
done for a while on the channel and that is
a more of a personal video that's unscripted
and sharing a bit more of my thoughts.
So I'm going to do a bit of a Q&A
answering some of the common questions
that I've seen popping up in the comments
but I also asked my Patreon
supporters for some questions.
I've written a few of those down in my
notebook here so I'll work through those
as well as generally sharing what I've been
up to. I'm going to start with the question
that I've used for the title of this video and it
was a comment that I received that asked me if I
had ever failed a test. I've looked through
plenty of tests now on the channel so it's
only a natural kind of question and apart from
maybe my real analysis midterm, I do have one
interesting story about failing tests but it's not
probably the kind of test that you would expect.
So one test that made me cry as a teenager
was the New Zealand Full License Driving test.
I took this when I was 16 and a half
and as the title says I failed it twice.
On my third try though I did pass so I have
my full license now but it wasn't without at
least a little bit of misery along the way. In New
Zealand you have three tests before you get your
driver's license. One is a theory exam that I got
a hundred percent on, the second one is a one hour
driving test where you do all sorts of things
like three-point turns and various maneuvers,
that I also aced I got 100, but the third
test is the full license test where it's
only a 20-minute drive and you go through a bunch
of hazard detection things and general assessment
of your driving. The first time taking the
test I did really well for the whole time,
hadn't done anything wrong, and we were driving
back to the testing facility to go over everything
and just on the last little corner
before getting to the destination
I got done for going over the speed limit. I was
going probably between 55 and 60 when the speed
limit was 50 there and I just can't even explain
that it was so out of character for me because I'm
actually a really slow driver and anyone that
knows me would complain that I drive too slow
so to have failed for going too fast is yeah kind
of ironic but um I think that nervous energy of
being in a testing situation just bubbled over
right towards the end there and I wasn't really
thinking straight. You think I might have learned
my lesson though but the second time I took the
test I did it in a different city, I did it in
Christchurch, whereas the first time I took it in
a pretty small town that didn't even have traffic
lights or multiple lanes or anything so it was
a very different style of driving to taking it
in a city but the second time I took the test,
again did really well for most of the time didn't
do anything wrong until the last intersection
just pulling into the car park there was a stop
sign and I didn't stop properly at the stop sign
something that of course you have to do. Again
I think I just didn't deal well with the stress
of being tested and watched while I'm driving
so that was that, got to be like Spongebob at
boating school for a while but eventually got it
on my third try. A little taste of failure for me.
This next question I must have had over
a hundred times now I get it all the time
someone asking me, 'where do you get all those
exam papers from?', 'How did you get special
access?' and sometimes people even shout at me in
all caps with these really abusive comments saying
'why aren't you using gloves to handle these
precious documents?'. Something along those lines.
So I just wanted to quickly say in the
descriptions of all those videos where I use
original documents, exams, things like that, I do
always link to the sites where I get them from and
I don't have any special access. I don't have the
original copy of Einstein's grades, rather I did
enough research to find them on the ETH library
website, that's the university that Einstein had
gone to. Doing research to find all those original
documents is probably the most time consuming part
of some of my videos, there are documents that I
would love to cover but they just aren't available
online and not being able to travel to the
libraries in Europe and look through the archives,
I've never been able to cover those things so I
do really appreciate when the universities put
them on digitized versions of the archives and
everything that I cover whether it's the exams,
the grades, or anything else, they're always
publicly available when I access them. I just
print them out the best I can on my little home
printer and then show them under the camera.
One question I should address is the common one
asking if I have an Instagram account, the answer
is no. I disabled my account quite a while ago
now and haven't really been on Instagram since.
For me instagram didn't feel like a positive
place or a way to spend my time, I would get
caught mindlessly scrolling through things and
I would often wish that I had enough willpower
to get off and go read a book or do something
else. It's a platform that kind of made me feel
bad about myself so it felt hypocritical for
me to be posting photos and trying to grab your
attention and try to make you stay on the app when
I myself wish that I was spending less time there.
There's also the general question of what
I've been up to, how I've been doing.
I guess for the last two years or so I've lived
a pretty reclusive life but to be honest that has
very little to do with COVID and lockdowns, that's
just the way that I live my life anyway and how
I like to be. So without having to travel or any
need to remove myself from this comfort zone I've
just been enjoying living a very quiet existence.
A huge amount of my time though has been spent on
my special project called Finding X which is this
animated short film that I've been working on for
probably over a year and a half now. It's been
really a massive undertaking. It all started
when I applied for a grant from YouTube and Screen
Australia, and you know I pitched something fairly
ambitious this 10 minute stop-motion animation all
about mathematics. At the time I had never even
done any stop-motion animation but I thought yeah
I could learn that, but pretty quickly I realized
I'm gonna need some people who know a lot more
about this than I do and so I found some amazing
people to help me with the animation, with the
production, the music, the sound, the story
and I'm really excited that this project is
nearly finished and I'm hoping to release
it by the end of January looking at the
25th of January to put it up on my channel
and it will represent really you know over a
year of my life that I've poured into this.
Pretty much everything that you'll see in the
film is handmade from felt so here's what some of
that looks like. There are little houses that our
characters live in including our main character X
who lives in this house here. X themself
came from this bit of felt here which
I've painted with watercolors to give it that
coloring. Our other characters include numbers,
symbols and roman numerals, all complete with
their own unique accessories, hats, glasses, hair
pieces. A small piece like the scarf might only
get seen for a split second in the final video
but it still took a lot of work to make. This
here is a little chalkboard that I made for a
fairground scene and these two windows are some
of my favorite assets, I modeled them off the four
color theorem especially the example given on the
wikipedia page. The four color theorem states that
you'll never need any more than four colors
to color in the regions of any map like this
such that no two adjacent regions have the same
color. So I had to make sure when I was cutting
out all of these pieces that no two regions of
the same color were touching and it was a little
tricky but I think I managed to do it right in the
end. So whenever I had any spare time I would be
sitting on the floor cutting things out, gluing
them together. The felt was then photographed and
some scenes have elements of real stop-motion but
for everything else the images got sent off to Ben
who brought them to life on the computer. I've
made a website for Finding X to share things like
the trailer and behind the scenes and I made it
using zyro who have kindly sponsored this video.
Zyro is a powerful and super affordable web
builder which is incredibly easy to use, you can
create a website in a manner of minutes and their
pricing starts from less than two dollars a month
with a 30 day money back guarantee and 24 7
support. This website I was able to set up
really quickly, I started by picking one of their
hundreds of templates and added the images, videos
and text that I wanted. The grid editor makes
it easy to line things up and Zyro automatically
adapts the website for mobile view. There's a
promotion on at the moment to celebrate the new
year and new projects so to get an exclusive
discount plus a custom domain and four months
free with any yearly plan use my code tibees or
click on the link down in the description. They're
really worth considering if you also have a
project that you want to easily share with people.
The next question I wanted to answer is one that
asked me to share a bit about my creative process
making videos and I think this makes sense to talk
about after having shared the progress of Finding
X with you because I have a lot of thoughts about
maybe my philosophy when it comes to content
creation and you know even a bit of confusion
there on what really is the best approach.
Always a motto that I really liked is one that my
mum says which is 'minimum effort, maximum gain'
and it kind of sounds a little bit rude almost but
I think it's kind of true especially with Youtube,
social media and growth on these sorts of
platforms. It seems more important to be
putting out a lot of content that isn't quite
perfect rather than taking ages to upload real
masterpieces and this is what you see with
my regular content. With my normal videos
they're far from perfect, they're often just made
entirely by myself and there are so many aspects
that in hindsight could be a little better
but really if I think about it, what would
the payoff be in terms of getting any extra
views if I spent you know many extra hours on
transitions or fancy sound and things like that.
I kind of for the most part think nah don't go
too fancy just put it up and people are there
for the core message anyway and me investing
all that extra time probably won't result in
many more views or or that much more enjoyment.
So then why have I spent a year and a half
painstakingly slaving over this Finding X project?
It is perfectionism to the level that every single
thing that you see in it has been through multiple
sets of edits, has passed through multiple eyes
and had multiple opinions on if it's the very best
thing for that particular spot and I really lived
and breathed every aspect of this project for so
long now. Given that there are multiple people
involved in it as well I feel like I can't release
any version of it that is less than perfect it's
been a lot of stress to do and i'm not convinced
that after all of that that it would perform any
better than any other regular video on my channel.
For most videos on Youtube I don't believe
that there is any correlation between effort
and success as measured in views. I know that my
most viewed video is definitely the one that had
the least effort put into it and even some of my
ones in the top 10 most viewed you know they're
kind of ones that I didn't expect to do well, they
just took off maybe thanks to the statistics of;
if you put out a lot of stuff at least maybe
something is bound to be good. I won't be upset
if Finding X gets less views than say this Q & A,
it's possible, but that's not really what Finding
X is about. It's not a project that I undertook
to get max views, I think there are many different
roads I could have taken if that was the goal.
I think Finding X is something that I'm always
going to be proud of. I think it looks really
beautiful, I think it's an approach to sharing
math to people in a way that I haven't really seen
before and I really hope that you enjoy it too.
In terms of my creative process for the rest of my
videos it starts off with quite a time-consuming
phase of research where I really like to
live in the topic for at least a few days.
I read everything about it that I can, maybe go
off on a tangent watching documentaries about
the topic on Youtube, really soak up all the
knowledge about whether it's a certain country,
their exams or a certain character from history.
And then I try to condense that into a script,
I only ever really script the face cam sections
of those videos. Usually that's the intro.
For anything that's overhead I feel like I can
breathe a sigh of relief and just talk off the top
of my head in those sections because I know don't
have to worry about looking at the camera, looking
good or saying sentences without too many cuts
and things like that. I can really just drop all
of the knowledge I know and it doesn't matter if
it comes out in a scrambled way. I can deal with
editing it together to be a succinct story later.
To do that editing probably takes me about a day
to a day and a half depending on how intensely
I'm working on it. I do the editing myself on
my laptop using final cut pro and I still use
my canon g7x as my main camera. It's probably
one of the least professional cameras to use for
something like this especially as my channel grows
but sometimes I joke that I don't want people
to see me in 4k especially if I have you know a
pimple or a bad hair day or something I don't want
people to be able to zoom too close into that.
I'm still trying to keep to that motto of keeping
things as simple as possible and my fairly minimal
setup for these videos seem to have worked alright
so far with only a few complaints here or there.
One of the questions I got was "three years later
are you still at peace with your decision to quit
the phd?" and the answer to that is yes I'm
still pretty happy that I left my phd and I
don't regret it yet. Having been three years now
a lot of my friends that I was doing PhD with
at the time have now graduated or are
graduating right now and are looking for
maybe post docs or other jobs so I do feel that
feeling of oh if I had stayed I would have been
graduating now and i'd be a doctor now and I
could be going out and doing those things too
but especially with it having just been new years
I always write out my goals around that time,
my goals for the year and things like that.
And you know i've noticed none of them actually
include anything that has a requirement for
a PhD so yeah I still don't feel like it's
something that I needed for the things I want to
do and I feel endlessly lucky and grateful to have
my audience on Youtube which I often think is a
little bit more powerful anyway and I still get
really cool opportunities coming my way. Next
week i've got a video coming out which is
a collaboration that I did with IBM about
quantum computing and i loved doing that,
that was like a dream thing to be able to work
on. Having said that i'm still so fascinated
with many questions in science and I don't
think I can ever leave that curiosity behind
and that's what attracted me to the PhD in the
first place. It was never about the credential,
it was about the experience and who you become
getting that opportunity to do research. If
anything I don't have plans to return to a PhD
program anytime soon but I have this pipe dream
of maybe approaching a local uni and asking if I
can work with them as sort of you know a research
assistant for a few months or something and
just being able to have a taste of that research
environment again and maybe pick and choose a few
different topics I'm interested in. I still don't
think i'd be able to stick to one niche topic for
the three or four years that it takes of a PhD.
Up next we have the mildly requested bookshelf
tour. This is just what I've got on here at the
moment here I've got my Newton's Principia
copy that I have used in a few videos.
Fun fact I bought this online and I didn't
like the cover that it originally came with
so I printed off this original cover and then
stuck it on with like transparent book tape.
This one looks like a stolen math book from school
but it's actually not at least I didn't steal it.
My mum loves going to op shops and she sometimes
gets me books as like a present which is really
nice of her but she knows I'm interested in
something to do with maths and physics so if
there's ever a book that has maths in the title
she'll probably bring it home for me. This one
she got me from the op-shop recently it is the
Journal of the Korean Mathematical Society. It's
literally a bunch of printed out really abstract
math papers from some July 2017 conference.
These are some more second-hand books this
one I got it's from, oops upside down, the
ambidextrous universe by Martin Gardner. A story
about Galileo's daughter that would probably make
for a good video one day. These Marcus Chown books
are pretty important to me because I bought these
when I was in high school with some book vouchers
that I won at school, they're probably some of the
first physicsy books that I ever really read. This
one here Fred Watson's Star Craving Mad, Fred is
an Australian astronomer and science communicator
and he was working at the Australian Astronomical
Observatory in Sydney when I was an intern there
so I got to meet him and spend some time with him
and so this book is actually signed. Dear Toby,
from one astronomy communicator to another,
with very best wishes for a sensational
astronomical career, all the best Fred.
It's funny to read this because
at the time he wrote this
I wasn't even making videos on Youtube this
has got nothing to do with my Youtube channel
he just knew I was involved with
some in-person science communication.
I've got A Mathematical Nature Walk, Contact by
Carl Sagan, Alice in Wonderland, A Little Book of
String Theory of which I have some bookmarks
in that show you I never made it all the way
to the end. I've got this little book in here
which I have a poem published in from school.
I might as well show you these library books
I've got out here now too. This is written by
George Gamow, Mr Tompkins In Wonderland dedicated
to Lewis Carroll and Niels Bohr. I haven't read
it yet so I don't have too much to say. After
making my recent video about Kepler's Somnium or
The Dream, I actually found a copy of
it in the library surprisingly enough.
Kind of wish I'd found this earlier instead of
having to just read everything off the computer.
For the most part when I look at my bookshelf I
think uh I wish I could read more. I'm such a slow
reader I don't know if it's good or bad, I try and
say that's good because at least I stop to think
about things you know between every few pages but
it also means I barely ever get anything finished.
This here is a little lunch box that I actually
got from Educon when I went to America back in
2019. They got someone to spray paint all of our
channel names onto these lunchboxes which I think
is so cute and so thoughtful so it deserves a
little spot on the shelf. Educon was probably
the best event I've ever been to because I got
to meet some of the creators who I've looked up
to for so long who are nothing but kind and
willing to help even the smallest creators.
Sometimes I think the highlight of my Youtube
career is having been able to mix with them
on something like equal terms. Last point
of business is a hair update because this
never otherwise makes it into frame, in
fact it's pretty hard to get it in now
but yes I do have absurdly long hair, no I haven't
had a haircut for probably 10 years. It's probably
just down to my knees at the moment or just
passed but there you go that's a hair update.
Thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my Patreon supporters,
a special shout out to today's
Patron dog of the day Yoyo